one of the most stunning natural
phenomena in our solar system has a
perennial nemesis the British weather
doctor John Taylor has an elegant
solution to a cloudy view though watch
the Eclipse above the clouds he invited
Sky News along for the ride
we took off from Stornoway in Scotland
under stormy skies but above the clouds
the view was uninterrupted
and we headed out over the Atlantic
Ocean towards Iceland
dr. Taylor was the inventor of the
thermostat that controls the electric
kettle to click it makes when yours is
boiled is down to him at 78 years old he
is still a keen pilot
you
the darkness came on fast
the plane was in the shadow of the moon
and as quickly as it had descended the
dark lifted but now heading back were in
the bright sunshine this was like before
the Eclipse doctor did not see the
shadow just keep brushing so quickly
Dean 100 miles an hour and you're
engulfed in it and then it moves on it's
really quite ominous but now the Eclipse
is still going on the moon is still in
front of the Sun and you put your glass
on this just in front of us and when you
put your glasses on it's the clearest
view is the most extraordinary beautiful
sight I've ever seen two and a half
hours after takeoff we came in to
Edinburgh Airport
you
dr. Taylor started making preparations
for his next slightly less spectacular
flight Tom Cheshire Sky News Edinburgh